good afternoon and welcome to preparing
your school for the digital sat webinar
we are so happy that you're able to join
us this afternoon to learn more about
the new digital sat and how KH Academy
can help support your teachers students
and um Community with this transition my
name is Elizabeth Hadley and I am a
district success manager supporting
several districts across the United
States with Con Academy so let's get
started started official digital SAT
prep with KH Academy so as you may know
uh KH Academy is the official partner
with college board meaning that our
strategies our tips our videos
explanations and practice questions are
aligned to the content that your
students will expect to see on the new
digital sat assessment some of the um
items that students can practice through
can are eight full length practice test
we have leveled exercise videos lessons
and strategies personalized practice to
each and every student tips and tricks
for your students to tackle the big test
day and of course instant feedback and
progress tracking as your students
practice we have two digital SAT prep
courses embedded in KH Academy we have
the reading and writing and the math
section something that my team's really
excited about to share with you is not
only are these course is Mastery enabled
meaning that students can track their
progress all year long students um
actually can engage with a signable
Content that teachers assign uh to the
students and I'll get into that and
exactly how that
works last but not least we have a
course challenge the course challenge
that you see at the bottom of the screen
here is a 30 question assessment that
helps students get on the right track
and see where they should start their
learning so we really highly suggest
that students start with the course
challenge to receive that personalized
learning path when they engage with our
digital sat courses on Con Academy the
digital sat course functions just like
any other course that you may be
familiar with or your teachers may be
familiar with um in Con Academy so they
are Mastery enabled and they look just
like our math courses that you may have
seen before in in the platform uh this
means that teachers are able to create
assignments they're able to view student
progress and hold students accountable
for their
learning in the past uh students would
link their college board account to KH
Academy to Res receive that personalized
practice but we know that linking to
college board was a very time consuming
process for many of our Educators and
we're pleased to announce that no longer
do students need to link their kot
Academy account to their college board
account because now students can take
that course challenge that I was just
speaking about the course challenge will
uh provide students a sampling of skills
on the content enabled in the digital
sat courses and that's going to
prioritize for the student exactly what
they should be working on to prepare for
the big test
day finally students can move through
the course at their own pace while
teachers do have the ability to assign
content and really Target in a
assignments and skills that may mirror
what they're working on in class
students can work through the course at
their own pace and they can move forward
to a new skill or A New Concept when
they actually feel ready and that's
something that we love to promote here
at KH Academy so let's Dive Right In
what is actually changing with the
digital sat this may be a review for
some of you and this may be new content
so I hope we all learned something as we
dive into what's changing with the new
SAT uh first and foremost the test is
shorter uh this is something many
educators are excited about because it
is a more condensed assessment and um
it's not taking hours and hours and
hours for students to complete we're
looking at a total test time of
approximately about two hours another
major change that you'll see at the top
of the screen is that uh there is no
more um essay on the digital
sat so let's take us through all of the
sections obvious viously the test will
be taken through a digital assessment
platform called blueb
book and there will be two sections the
reading and writing section and the math
section each section will have two
modules and within the two modules
students will experience a multi-stage
adaptive testing format meaning that how
students answer questions in module one
will dictate and Target the type of
questions that they receive
in module
two for reading and writing each module
will have 27 questions and students are
given 32 minutes per
module additionally with that
elimination of the essay there's also
new question
formats for math two modules 22
questions and 35 minutes and the biggest
change to the math section is a
calculator is now allowed on all
sections of the digital SAT Math section
so that is something very important to
make sure that Educators know across the
board that now a calculator is allowed
on the math
section reading and writing let's take a
look at just the reading and writing
section the reading and writing test
will focus on not only the
interpretation and evaluation of of text
but also the analysis and the editing of
cont content level and grade level
specific text sets the blueprint
published by the college board has
questions that are divided into four
categories information and ideas craft
and structure expression of ideas
Standard English conventions and off to
the right hand side of your screen you
can see the um fact that craft and
structure really consists of about 28%
of that assessment so that's really
important for us to know as we're
engaging and engaging our students in
practice that um a a big portion of that
assessment is from the craft inst
structure uh category there so what's
changed with the SAT reading and writing
test uh for one the test is now combined
and we did speak about that that they're
no longer two separated sections uh the
reading and writing is now combined into
one
section additionally there are shorter
passages for students to engage with so
as they're going through those questions
in the reading and writing section
please keep in mind that the passages
are much shorter um meaning that
there'll be um a short chunk of text and
a question that follows related to that
chunk of text uh that's really important
for teachers to know because as they're
practicing with students throughout the
the course of the year as they prepare
for sat um that they're no longer are
having to read very long text sets I
believe that this allows for ELA and
English uh teachers to provide more
frequent practice with students because
they're not having to read such a very
long text so definitely keep that in
mind and of course on KH academy uh
students will have plenty of
opportunities to practice with these
shorter pieces of text and text
dependent
questions and of course the digital sat
includes new types of questions um with
greater number of passages requiring new
strategies for our students to engage
with those
texts okay the math blueprint so let's
move on over to math the digital SAT
Math is also divided into four sections
algebra advanced math problem solving
and data analysis and Geo and
trigonometry um as you see in the
blueprint you'll notice that over uh
35% of the assessment the new digital
SAT Math comes from the algebra section
and in KH Academy not only do students
have avail ility and access to our
digital sat course we also have an
algebra course as well that students can
engage with keeping in mind these four
sections are essential of um for our
students to be proficient in because
these are what the college board says
are needed uh for College and Career
Success so again let's uh return back to
that calculator usage keeping in mind a
Desmos calculator is allowed and will be
in the platform for students to engage
with and students can also bring their
own graphing calculator so not only will
students have access to the digital
Desmos calculator in the platform they
can also still bring their handheld
calculator if that is uh what the
student chooses to do of course uh
shorter test updated format digital
platform and the questions are divided
into three categories foundational
questions medium questions and advanced
questions and just like the reading and
writing section the average length of
the word problems have also been reduced
as well so keep in mind the questions
are not as uh wordy and and and as long
as they used to be so they're a lot more
complex there are two formats of
questions on the digital SAT Math
section on the left hand side you'll see
that there are student produced
responses meaning that this will require
students produce their own answer
and on the right hand side of my screen
multiple choice and that is what we are
typically all used to that there are
four possible answer choices and
students must select an
answer within Con Academy we offer not
only the reading and writing course but
also the math course reading and writing
we have hundreds of official digital sat
items that are aligned with 11 skills
for students to work through in math
there are 37 skills meaning there are
thousands of items for our students to
practice with to prepare for the digital
sat within those skills students will
find not only in-depth lesson articles
but video worked examples practice
exercises and three difficulty
levels there's also the course challenge
quizzes and unit tests and skill
progress data available to the student
and to the teacher
and again by partnering with the College
Board we know that these items that the
students are working through are
authentically aligned to the content on
the digital
sat at KH Academy we believe in this
idea of Mastery learning Mastery
learning is an educational approach
where students focus on fully
understanding the content that they're
working through and not moving on when
they're not ready I'm going to play a
quick video on Mastery learning and then
we'll come back and disc what does it
mean for our students to engage with
Mastery learning have you ever really
tried to learn something and you just
couldn't it can make you feel like
you're not so smart right well it's not
your fault and it's not your teacher's
fault it's just our traditional approach
to learning we go through school and we
accumulate gaps you're a bit shaky on
pre-algebra but you move on to algebra
Anyway by the time you get to calculus
You' got lots of gaps if if enough gaps
build up you eventually hit a wall
calculus makes no sense and that can be
frustrating but what if there were a
different way to learn that's Mastery
learning unlike traditional learning
where all students move in lock step
with Mastery learning you go at your own
pace you progress through questions at
just the right level for you if you get
50% right the first time it's not a big
deal try as many times as you need get
feed back as you learn and help when you
need it teachers can track your progress
identify any gaps and give you
one-on-one attention Decades of research
shows Mastery learning works now you
have the tools to make it possible are
you ready to learn
anything so as mentioned in the video
Mastery learning is this idea that
students fully and deeply understand the
content that they're learning and not
only does this promote an idea of
Mastery but also an insurance that we
know that students are understanding and
fully deepening that um skill set with
the skills they're learning and so uh
this not only leads to to long-term
retention um but just a better approach
to to fully learning our Concepts
through Con
Academy I'm going to take us through uh
the actual Con Academy website now and
the platform and I invite you to open up
another Tab and visit con academy.org
and if you have an account go ahead and
log in um if you're not you are more
than welcome to just uh watch our screen
but I do invite you to open up your
account if you have one now and we're
going to take a look at how the Con
Academy course content is organized and
uh in specific to the digital sat
courses all of our courses including the
digital sat ones are not only organized
into courses but there's also units and
lessons and within those lessons you'll
see instructional videos articles
practice exercises and all of that is
assignable content meaning the teacher
can assign that to students and track
their progress on whatever they have
assign to students if the teacher
chooses not to assign content the
students have free will to work through
these courses and work through each of
the
units so moving over to the Con Academy
platform when you log in you're able to
see your your dashboard or any classes
that you've created and I'm actually
going to go up to the courses tab here
where you're able to view all of the
courses that we have available on the
platform but because we're focusing on
that transition to the digital sat today
we're going to click into the digital
sat under the test prep section under
courses now I'm going to focus on the
math for right now this is the digital
SAT
Math and when I click into that we are
now opened up into the entire course on
the Le hand side you'll see those units
I was just talking about starting with
the first unit about the digital sat
this is the very first unit that
students can engage with and look at
what's actually changing with the SAT
and how to prepare for it so that's
really the first unit that we suggest
students start with these units are
almost like chapters in a textbook okay
so the digital SAT Math has 111 skills
for students to work through within 13
units when you click on the unit you're
able to see the topics that are within
the unit so after I clicked on unit two
you can see that we are looking at
solving linear equations linear equation
word problems linear relationship word
problems and within each of these skills
are videos articles and practice quizzes
and those practice quizzes is where
students can demonstrate their Mastery
learning with each of these
skills in the lower leftand corner is
the course challenge that is that uh
personalized practice Journey or
practice Learning Journey that I
suggested that students take as soon as
they start with the digital sat course
so this is a 30 question test that will
uh test students on their understanding
of a variety of skills from the
course so I'm going to give everyone in
the webinar a moment to not only
navigate to the courses through con
academy.org but take a look at what's
available in our digital sat courses for
those that are unable to join on another
screen I will uh walk through several of
these courses and demonstrate some of
that that content and what I would like
you to do is put in the question and
answer uh box what do you notice or what
do you think there's one thing that you
could start implementing with students
right now to get them ready for the
digital sat using our con Academy
course so just a moment to look at our
courses look at the digital sat
course and think about what is one item
you could implement
right now to get students
ready and this is just a moment for you
to look through the
course and for those that are unable to
join on another screen I am clicking
through some of our content so you can
check it
out
again this content is all available to
you right now today by visiting con
academy.org
clicking into the
courses and navigating to the digital
sat
course and clicking into either the
digital SAT Math or the digital sat
reading and
writing and as I'm clicking through I
hope you're able to see we have lots of
Articles and videos and frequently asked
questions like you see here on the
screen and uh quizzes and unit quizzes
throughout our
content now at the top you'll notice
that students will have uh these boxes
okay and I'm going to move back over to
our uh slide deck here so we can talk
about Mastery learning so we've already
talked about this idea of Mastery
learning but how can students and
teachers track this um so as students
start working through our content
students can demonstrate their
understanding of the skills in these
courses uh through the four Mastery
levels that you're seeing here on the
screen the four Mastery levels embedded
in our content are not
started
attempted
familiar proficient and mastered and
these levels help you track your
progress in the students areas of
improvement that they need to work on
obviously mastered means that students
have demonstrated at least twice that
they understand SC the content and have
received a 100% on a
quiz proficient is when students have
demonstrated 100% on a skill in a quiz
at least
once and then of course attempted and
familiar are students that are still
working on Mastery and proficiency with
those skills and as students work their
boxes on these skills will start to fill
in with the appropriate Mastery level
color and as students hover over these
they're able to see exactly what skill
that
is now if I move over to the teacher
dashboard so what does this look like
for teachers I'm going to click into a
digital SAT Math
course and teachers are able to see what
proficiency level or what Mastery level
here that our students are falling under
for each of our skills so here is a
skill solving linear equations and
inequalities at the foundational level
and as students work they'll start to be
categorized under the attempted familiar
proficient or mastered range in this
example my students haven't been working
too much and they haven't even started
on this skill but as students start
working they'll start to fall into one
of these categories this is a great way
for teachers to differentiate what the
students really need based on their
Mastery level
so how to use course and unit Mastery
goals in our digital sat courses
teachers have the ability to assign a
course Mastery goal and unit Mastery
goals let's talk a little bit about what
these are course Mastery and unit
Mastery work hand inand and they work
together to track students progress unit
Mastery focuses on individual specific
topics while the course Mastery is the
entire course
so let's walk through an example if I
were to start my students today on the
digital SAT Math course I can assign a
course Mastery goal and set that goal to
be due right before sat or right before
they take the
SAT that's a goal that this teacher can
set and it stays all year long until the
due date the goal is for students to
master at least 80% of the content keep
in mind those Mastery levels that we we
just talked
about as students start working the
teacher has the ability to assign a unit
Mastery so these are the individual
units within the course and teachers can
assign just one particular unit for
students to work through at any given
time so if the teacher is working on
linear equations in the classroom she
can assign that unit that has linear
equations and track their Mastery with
that particular unit
as students work through the units it
contributes to their overall course
Mastery goal we suggest using both
Mastery goals throughout the year to
track students progress through the
entire course let me show you how to
assign these and get started after the
teacher has made classes and added
students over here on the left side
navigation bar is an assign
button under assign under Mastery goals
select the course that you want to
assign a a course Mastery goal to you
can select any of the courses that are
available but since we're talking about
the digital sat today I will make sure
that I have the digital SAT Math for
reading one
checked for this example I'll pick the
digital sat reading and writing one and
make sure that my radio dial is on
course
Master over here is where you can set
your due date so if I'm going to have
students engage with the sat in I don't
know late March I may set this for an
April 1
deadline and then down here all the
teacher needs to do is Click create
course
goal and Bam the student will have that
course goal uh given out to their
account and it will notify the student
that the teacher has assigned a course
Mastery goal as students work teachers
can go back to the left side navigation
bar
here under
progress and they're able to click on
their Mastery goal progress and monitor
how much of the content each of their
students in the classes have mastered
throughout the year so for example Rees
has mastered
26% of this course Janet on the other
hand has mastered 49% of the
course the goal is for students to reach
at least 80% Mastery this is a great way
for teachers to track that students are
going through the content they're going
through the skills they're practicing
and they're achieving
Mastery now remember we talked a little
bit about unit Mastery goals let me show
you
those from the left side navigation bar
under
assign select the course that you'd like
to assign a unit Mastery goal
to for this example I'm using the
digital SAT Math course and underneath
this radio dial unit Mastery are all the
different units within the course so the
teacher can decide to assign foundations
of algebra which contains eight
skills and set a shorter due date for
students to master those eight School uh
skills so possibly maybe by January 3rd
we would expect students to be finished
with that course
and then just click create unit goal and
that will assign a unit goal for those
eight skills to the students this is a
great way to progress monitor throughout
this the entire course and progress
monitor students abilities uh between
now an SAT school day or when they sit
for the
SAT so monitoring assignments from your
teacher dashboard this is something new
to our digital sat courses that we're
super excited about because teachers can
assign specific videos articles um
quizzes unit quizzes to students and
then actually see the students score and
when they completed
it heading back over into the platform
here under assignments there is this
assign
button so if I was just getting started
with my students on engaging them with
this digital SAT Math course I may want
to just first assign the about the digal
sat that is the very first unit in our
course and it's a great way to get
students comfortable with the fact that
the SAT is changing to a digital
format by simply clicking assignments
and assign I can look at that first unit
I can even preview as a teacher what's
actually in that unit so you can see in
that first unit there's a lesson an
article a video couple more articles
with frequently asked questions and then
there's an entire section on preparing
for the SAT this is a great way to start
our students
off so once I've previewed all of this
content over to the right hand side move
my monitor over I can
select exactly which content I want to
uh give to my students I don't suggest
doing too many at once it's great to
chunk this material for students so here
I've selected just the first uh couple
articles and videos
and up here in the upper right hand
corner is a sign and what I love about
this is I can assign this to all my
students or I can assign it to a group
of students so think about in a
classroom maybe I would want one group
to work on the article in the video and
another group to work on the about the
digital sat math test and the frequently
asked questions so teachers have that
functionality to assign this to all or
select students
they can also assign this to multiple
classes at once so if they've set up uh
several class periods you can assign it
all right here one at a time all at
once and you can also set a due date so
a start time and a due date that you
would expect students to have this
completed
by once the teacher has
assigned the assignments over here on
the left hand
navigation bar there's a scores button
and this is where teachers can view the
students names exactly what has been
assigned to the students and what their
score was if it was a video they'll
simply see a check mark But if it was a
quiz they'll see a a actual score like
you see here on our
screen this is downloadable to CSV and
can be transferred to many uh grade
books as well from that EX
file we know that parents are a vital uh
part in a Student Success not only on
the SAT but in their educational career
and please know that we do have a con
Academy app that's available in several
languages so you can reach all of your
parents uh not only is the app available
in multiple languages but it allows
parents to access all of the content
that you uh previewed today in any of
our courses they can track their
students progress they can actually set
goals and monitor those goals for their
children they have access to the
practice exercises and
quizzes and they can also monitor their
students Mastery in the courses that the
teacher has assigned so thinking about
what you've learned about the digital
sat today and all of the changes that
are occurring and what is available in
the platform when you're thinking about
a school wide approach or even a
district-wide approach definitely
consider Con Academy districts Con
Academy districts allows your uh
leadership teams and your District teams
to take a systematic approach to
implementation and allows you to not
only roster your students automatically
through clever class link but it allows
you to monitor those skills and those
Mastery Levels by skills that I was
showing you by school by teacher or by
District to find out more about KH
Academy districts please visit our con
Academy District's uh website and with
that partnership not only will you save
time and provide actionable insights and
be able to see and drill down to actual
skills from our courses but you also
receive a district success manager that
aligns your school or District's goals
to
implementation and you also get um the
highlevel uh reports so you can drill
into the classes and the and the schools
and on the entire district and save time
um by monitoring your your teachers and
your students
progress um again you do get that uh
professional rostering through class
link or uh clever so your teachers don't
have to to make uh their own classes and
add their students and of course
professional learning is included with
KH Academy District
uh so teachers feel confident in how to
set up their classes assign Mastery
goals and look at that assignable
content and so we love um being able to
train our teachers and get them ready
and get all of the students ready for
the digital sat and so we thank you so
much for your time today and we welcome
any questions that you have in the chat
for us to answer in regards to any of
the content that we provided today and
again thank you so much for joining our
webinar on preparing students for the
digital sat and we hope that you get in
there and engage your students with our
two new courses the digital sat reading
and writing and our math course thank
you so
much